in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 4th, on which we commemorate,
the venerable Martha, mother of Simeon's stylites, of the wonderful mountain.
Born in Antioch, St. Martha had made a vow of virginity,
but she submitted to the desire of her parents and married a certain John of Odessa.
This was after a revelation from the Holy Forerunner,
who announced to her that she would give birth to a new chosen vessel,
St. Simeon of the wonderful mountain.
She was spared the normal pains of childbearing,
and for forty days after the birth took the child to the Church of St. John the Baptist.
Her husband, having died during an earthquake that destroyed a great part of the city,
the saint received another vision in which she saw herself caught up to heaven to present her son to God.
When St. Simeon had withdrawn to the wonderful mountain,
Martha, who lived in a suburb of Daphne, often went to visit him.
She spent all her time in churches, where she prayed with compunction,
standing, her attention fixed, holy on God.
No one had ever seen her sit down on a Sunday, or speak with anyone in the church.
She gave abundant alms, received strangers, and humbly washed their feet,
clothed, those who were naked, fed the hungry, and gave baptismal tunics to those catacumins
who did not have the means to acquire them.
She likewise provided the funeral cloths needed to bury the indigent.
The day when, with great solemnity, St. Simeon took up permanent residence on his column in the year 551,
his mother led the procession, holding across in her hand, and singing,
save us, O Son of God, crucified for us, Lord glory to thee, Alleluia.
She afterwards went several times to the saint to ask him to intercede for the people undergoing trials,
including the time when plague was ravaging Antioch in 542,
and when there were earthquakes in Antioch and the Constantinople area in 551.
Three months before her blessed entering into rest in the year 551,
she was told by angels of the glory awaiting her, in the company of her son and spiritual father.
She asked to be buried in the grave reserved for strangers at Daphne,
where shortly before, Thomas of Odessa, a holy man had been buried.
After her death, however, St. Simeon transferred her body which remained incorrupt to the wonderful mountain.
It was placed on the right side of the church, but the saint later appeared to her son and told him to build a tomb in the southern part of the church.
A relics were transferred with great solemnity accompanied by many miracles.
Sometime later, it was in this chapel that St. Simeon was buried beside his mother.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.